I am Colleen Farley I live in Miami
Florida I am the author of the shape of
data which will be coming out this next
year and I've focused a lot on public
health
um
social sciences and a lot of
mathematical tools that can be used to
study both of these
so let's go through some of the tools
we're not going to get into details here
too much just kind of what the tools are
and how we can use them
so the first tool is something called
persistent homology which comes from a
branch of math called topology this
branch is not real concerned with how
your data is put together in the local
sense it's more about how your data is
connected
um so basically we create a series of
distance based objects and look at
features across them
this does connect back to geometry and
the curvature and the distances that you
define in your data but it's a little
broader of an overview
the next tool is Foreman Ricci curvature
which is a network science metric we
just had a great uh two presentations on
network science and how useful it is
um this tool measures the curvature on
the graph so in physics when we have a
lot of matter in the same spot it pulls
everything towards it so black holes are
going to pull planets towards it pull
your spaceship towards it
um the same thing happens in networks
when we have a lot of things that are
connected in the same area of the graph
processes that happen on a graph tend to
get pulled into there so if you're
looking at marketing campaigns it tends
to Clump around that area if you're
looking at epidemics that's typically
where you're going to find a lot of
cases and in general this is a very
useful tool for understanding change
points and behavior over time on graphs
there's a newer branch of machine
learning that's been really useful
generative Ai and some of the geometry
tools that evolve these creations have
been playing a major role in being
having people being able to develop
things through AI without actually
having to know much coding so basically
there's a deep learning algorithm that
can take your text and create an image
and there are tools in Geometry that are
able to evolve and kind of massage out
what you want from the image this is an
example on the left of a place that does
not actually exist but I created it with
one of the open source tools out there
and this can be really useful as we'll
see
so let's get into the applications
so a few of the projects that I've used
persists in homology on are looking at
Urban growth tipping points
um so as cities grow
um especially if there's not a lot of
infrastructure or planning going on when
cities start evolving we can run into
problems with infrastructure we can run
into problems with public health and
sanitation and we can end up with
environmental issues if there's a
Tipping Point that
results in a lot of growth without
enough time to build all of the things
needed to keep a city running we can
also look at climate change and
understand when there are points of no
return When the climate is going to tip
when populations aren't safe living in
an area anymore and this is really
important to be able to relocate
populations before a disaster happens in
their area or before the area is unlim
livable such as Barrier Islands
communities on Rivers areas near the
Sahara which are dealing with a lot of
deforestation and evolution into desert
climates
in addition
um with the recent covid epidemic um
this is also really important in
understanding epidemic growth so that we
can position resources especially in
communities that may not have a lot of
starting resources being able to
understand where and when we need to
place these resources can go a long way
in preventing the spread of an epidemic
and limiting the loss of life during one
Ferman Ritchie curvature is another tool
that I use a lot in my work
um right now there's a huge crisis in
food prices so this is impacting a lot
of communities middle class populations
are finding themselves being driven back
into poverty with Rising food prices and
there's a lot of food insecurity that
has started especially since the Ukraine
conflict so understanding when prices
are going to change what prices are
going to change and where they're going
to change allows social programs to be
able to meet these needs it allows
food Aid programs to be able to know how
much Aid they may have they may need to
meet the need of the communities as well
as what governments can do locally to
reduce the price of food and help
populations get through rough patches
um one of the first times that I use
these models on a project was during the
Dr Congo 2018 Ebola outbreak
um the outbreak happened in an
under-resourced area of the country and
getting resources in
the areas impacted was difficult for
ngos and for local responders and being
able to understand where and when the
next wave of the epidemic would hit
helped be able to position those
resources to respond accordingly and in
areas of greatest need
there's another use more common in
marketing but also with behavior change
of understanding where in a social
network or a geographic Network an
intervention can be done so say you want
to
have a smoking cessation program or a
sexual health education program that
tips Behavior change at a population
level
understanding how your network is put
together and who has the influence in
the network to be able to impact change
on a population level without having the
resources to intervene on everyone
having these type of tools is really
really useful to be able to
selectively Target
different populations or different
individuals within the population to
affect the system level change
so last we have generative AI
um one of the things that I found is
that this is very useful in public
health education so during the covet
outbreak we had Mass campaigns
vaccination campaigns to try to help
improve population health and protect
vulnerable populations however there are
a lot of caveats with doing Public
Health in remote places with certain
populations
um
being able to make something culturally
relevant is really important um so
people who look like the community
um being the
image or the person speaking is really
important to be relatable
um and generative AI allows us to create
culturally relevant images for these
campaigns
in addition
um
they're really useful as a way to be
able to do this with under resource
areas
areas that don't have maybe as much
infrastructure around creating videos
creating uh image campaigns creating
public service announcements having this
technology allows the resources to go
further
um long time ago
um when I was working on HIV education
in South Africa
um
there wasn't a lot to go on and a lot of
it had to be developed on the Fly and
that's very hard to do when you're in a
rural community it's a lot of finding
people positioning
whatever skit or whatever materials need
to be created actually creating those
materials it used to take a lot of time
20 years ago but now with generative AI
we can tell our algorithm what we want
to generate generate 10 images or 100
images and then look through them for
what's most likely to resonate with the
population and that's really impactful
and I think in the future we're going to
be seeing a lot more of these
Technologies being leveraged in fields
that might not have used these in
marketing in public health
um
in a social program awareness campaigns
um pretty much anything that needs to
get the information out particularly in
a visual manner so a lot of areas of the
world have a lot of local languages and
somebody who is a native speaker of that
language might know some of the more
dominant language
messages can get lost in translation or
there might be a need to hire a lot of
translators to get the information out
there and this technology promises to
really help solve a lot of those
barriers to Public Health interventions
social policy
announcements even just getting
information about what resources exist
to these populations
so one of the things that I'm really
passionate about is the need for
representation
um so if we don't collect data on people
who look a certain way or speak a
certain language or come from a certain
area of the country or the world we
don't have that data for algorithms to
learn from and those populations may not
have their needs met if we don't have
that representation on Tech teams we
don't have that perspective of how there
might be barriers to adopting the
technology or having the technology work
correctly within that population so it's
really important that we consider
different
cultures and different subgroups so that
everyone can participate I think we're
at a Tipping Point within Tech of
those who are benefiting a lot from it
and those that haven't benefited much
and if we keep keep going this way and
some populations have a lot more
representation than others I think we're
going to be seeing more and more
division along the lines of technology
so that's really important especially
within social good projects that we have
representation from the community that
the community has ownership in data
input into how this is going to be used
or impact their community
so there are a lot of good resources out
there
um I'm gonna make this presentation
public on my LinkedIn
um so feel free to reach out to me feel
free to look at these resources for the
tools that are out there persistent
homology has a lot of packages
that exists in R and python text to
image open Ai and night Cafe have some
really great tools and for Foreman
Richie curvature I have code in Python
and an R for different network
applications and feel free to reach out
to me